uh they have
destroyed that masjid and that is the
wrong thing but do you know how many
temples in kashmir were burnt 350
temples are we settling scores
no
hindus and muslims are like the
montagues and capulets of india we've
been warning for centuries
[Music]
growing up
i was taught to stay away from the other
side
can the agrees please step forward
it wasn't said so strongly
nothing really there was generally an uh
non-appreciation of me hanging out with
hindu friends so there was not a
clear thing that don't hang out with
hindus but
discouraging where are you going
he's a hindu you don't even know how he
they would have cooked
why are you going to the ambassador
party or something whereas if i have a
muslim friend he was somewhat more
welcome
so yeah in my family i think i have
actually seen my parents neglect a lot
of my muslim friends and very strongly
my mother specifically walk up to me and
tell me that
don't make muslim friends
or you know whenever there was a muslim
friend's birthday party she would tell
me not to go there so there was this
very cold environment like i would see
my mother not treating them very well
not sitting with them or trying to even
initiate a discussion it really needs to
be stopped you can't let your kids grow
in such a venomous environment that it
ultimately takes a toll on them and when
they grow up they start
you know just hating the other community
to such an extent that they can't even
engage in discussions with them
can we have the disagreers come forward
my experience was quite the opposite in
my house
actually my sister's best friend was
muslim and she used to live in our
colony and for every diwali it's like
she didn't have anywhere to go or
anything to do so she used to spend
diwali with us so my family's been very
accepting so for my parents it was never
a choice because most of the my friends
were muslims only so there was no choice
for them to
stop me somewhere but yes they it was
communicated to our friend never
marry a girl outside your uh what i
really enjoy whenever whenever someone
from uh a different religion would come
to the house then the the level of
curiosity that my parents would have
and that's also something very you know
bad about a society after 1 000 years of
coexistence there is still curiosity how
dumb are we yeah like you still don't
know about the other person
i've been married to a muslim boy by my
own will and choice of course against my
parents well they still don't speak to
my husband at all
they have cordial relations with me
which i think have
over the time come to accept that it's
okay if they don't want to talk to him
it's their decision at the end of the
day and i need to respect it
someone i know has died because of this
conflict
we being kashmiri pundits
are treated as a minority community
community in german kashmir
and
because of this
religious extremism
my father
was
assassinated
when i was at the age of 15 or 16. all
the house was coordinated by militants
and he was taken from from that my place
and
he was assassinated because of this this
religious conflict certain innocence are
being targeted
and
if if the if the extremism
and conflicts
will go on
such things will happen
i think a lot of us
are just tongue-tied for now
but um if i may i think i just
have had a lot of respect for you like
right now because i think it takes a lot
to be a first-hand victim of a crime and
then still not develop that hatred and
get let that hatred get so much to you
that you start blaming an entire
community for it because at the end you
have to realize that an individual or
few individuals belonging to that
community were actually responsible for
it and not the entire community so i
think if we actually had people like you
who were so practical and understanding
we wouldn't be in the situation we are
in today no that's actually very true um
i've spent a lot of time in jammu and
kashmir my father was in the army we
were posted there for a long time i've
seen a lot of terrorism and a lot of
violence in front of me we didn't go to
school for many months because of that
so i've lost out big chunks of my
childhood initially when you had
introduced yourself and you said you
were a kashmiri pandit i was immediately
filled with fear
because i've had a lot of negativity
from
people who tend to harbor hate against
people
with literally just my surname
for of course things that have happened
terrible in their lives
but
to see somebody emerge from such a
situation and then still
come out the other side with the level
of maturity that you're able to
you know show right now it's it's really
incredible to see yeah what you have
been through given that despite that
personal tragedy you have managed to
keep
yourself just and fair my salute to you
and
if it matters you know i i doubt it does
but
as a part of a muslim community i am
terribly sorry for your loss see that's
the problem
i mean you can be sorry you can be sorry
to him why do you have to take the blame
for it exactly exactly that is something
that i don't understand none of my
business not my problem some people did
it i am the representative for myself
that doesn't make me absolute in the
sense to represent that entire culture
it's just a tiny facet it does no you
know actually why when you start being
apologetic for the entire community is
actually when you start giving the other
side the chance to blame the entire
community
made a point uh so she said that like if
we if everybody was like him we wouldn't
be here at all but i want to just take
to the other side because
to go what he has gone through i believe
the pain would be immense and if that
means that i lash out at society at the
perpetrators at whoever or whatever was
responsible i believe that there is
scope for understanding
those kind of violent actions absolutely
not i so disagree with that point of
view we'd be living in an uncivilized a
lawless society we actually start
propagating thoughts like this that you
know being violent is okay at a point
your aggression your
you know you're being upset at the
situation the immense pain that you have
felt i'm sure people are going to
understand but saying that
you know it's justified for me to be
if i understand what he's trying to say
is if he goes out because his family was
subjected to violence
and he
killed somebody what he's saying
actually that killing somebody is bad
that is not a justification for killing
but probably what he's saying is that
when it comes to punishing him yeah the
history which existed yeah so that
should serve as not a defense against
his crime but a
circumstance me so well
but this mitigating
how is that going to change anything
exactly i think that's the middle ground
is how does that make him different from
the people who has assassinated his
father how does that make him different
then see what because he also went ahead
and shot those people these people shot
his community so where is the difference
an answer to that so we can we can
justify by doing through individuals but
blaming a complete community is not
justified so that is that is what
pallavi and i also agree on that muslims
and
hindus can can bridge those those gaps
because there are some negative energies
which which will pull you in in your way
but you we need to be tolerant we need
to be very much patient about the
actions which we are doing
the government has created more divide
between hindus and muslims
really
are you guys not coming forward
so um i think of course you have reports
after reports in fact there is a new
york times post that has clearly said
and i quote that you know
the date of hate crime in india gets
released based on who the hater is
so when the government of india decides
to release a date on hate crimes in
india
and it
excludes lynchings of minorities and
only puts forward you know certain facts
where the majority is favored crimes
against majority i think of course the
government has a huge agenda to serve in
pleasing the majority you know if there
would have been a time angled to this
problem that would have made it you know
much more simpler for all of us because
i feel
post independence
all the governments in this country
have actually done nothing good for the
majority and for them for the minority
on on a way you know social sense right
economic indicators we are not counting
in so the governments have definitely
done you know that's why we are where we
are right now make no mistake
government since 1950s wouldn't have
done anything i agree with you
but 2014 onwards we have a government
who has an official policy to
discriminate against muslims
we have this kurbani the sacrifice of
the animal and it takes place at our
village and we go to village and bring
back the meat
from last two years we are not bringing
back the meat because we believe
traveling with the meat is very
dangerous they'll stop you and they'll
link you saying that it's cow
so it's this government has multiplied
hate and hate crimes exponentially it is
not something which is just happening
and they're apathetic about it this is
their policy and these are you know
seasoned politicians making very absurd
claims you know that you should go to
pakistan and all and you and i may think
that they're buffoons and idiots but
what they're doing actually is they're
normalizing it yeah unlike congress and
which this politician has said it very
right congress may be corrupt i agree
with you but this government has
overtaken the
institutions so completely
the judiciary the investigating agencies
the media yeah yeah
so
i i think all of that was already
you know
before this must have done this what we
are seeing now is a support towards
basically
this supported blatantly it's happening
it's happening without any regret that
they're violating the problem is the
degree of violating law there's open
support for it when did we see previous
governments supporting it they at least
had the knack and the shame to go ahead
and oppose it even on the face of it
even though you know in your head you
know there must have been some way had a
hand in this but they never supported it
openly what we see now is open blatant
shameless support and it has led to such
violent situation on the ground like he
correctly said people are being lynched
for just carrying meat
i don't think it's the government who
did the lynchings and the people who did
the lynchings they have been arrested
and even our prime minister has said
several times that it's uh has renounced
those acts so i don't think it's the
government who's not doing it's a law
and order issue in up and it should be
looked at as that
secondly i don't think the government is
increasing the divide between hindus and
muslims i think the divide has always
been there since the partition second of
all
uh speaking to the ramander issue
there my stance is
the muslims have thousands of all over
the world but ram was born only at one
place right so i personally believe that
the ram man they should have been there
and the the supreme court has given uh
islamic society the right to build a
mosque right beside
and like it would be like why would we
ever want to take
kaaba away from you it's like that that
place is too special to us then it is to
you and just out of magnanimity i would
like it just it would be
magnanimous of the muslims to just you
know give that uh but i don't i'm not
really i'm not really emotional about
that issue it could have gone either way
and i would have been fine with it what
you're saying is that the muslims should
have shown magnanimity is what the
general view would have been and the
supreme court has gone by it just
because they're minority they're weak
they're less in number let them come
forward and show magnanimity majority
why should we show mcdonald and let's
not forget that a mosque did exist at
that place that was demolished there is
proper videographic evidence to show
that people were on top of the tomb and
they demolished that mosque and then you
say give it to us give the place to us
because ram was born here and let me get
your facts right there has been a
affidavit in the supreme court by the
government itself stating that there is
no evidence whatsoever in fact by the
archaeological society of india also
that there is no fact whatsoever to
state and to confirm that lord ram was
actually born at that place so your
basic foundation of why the judgment is
good is
flawed in itself so i just never wanted
to go on this mandarin
kind of a thing but but but i just want
to clarify here maybe
anybody who has done on on a masjid they
have
destroyed that masjid and that is the
wrong thing but do you know how many
temples in kashmir have burnt 350
temples are we settling scores exactly
that doesn't justify one
i was at work and the entire debate
about ca and nrc was going on and
working in news means that's a very big
discussion topic if i was to ever voice
an opinion the immediate rebuttal it's
often said in jest but that doesn't of
course make it okay is oh why are you
bothered you can just go back to
pakistan
even though i have absolutely no
affiliation but my identity is then
brought into question my loyalty towards
my country is brought into question by
these things it goes back all the way to
like middle school as well
hindus and muslims can co-exist
peacefully in india
really oh my god
of course yeah you are not born bigot
you are turned into one by all these
politicians and all the men who wants to
keep their power to themselves and don't
want to work so they need things to
divide people i mean i think we've been
living fairly peacefully to be very
honest
there there have been some incidences
there has
obviously been a spike but look at us i
mean we are having such a sound
conversation and there is has definitely
been an increment in the number of
inter-religious marriages you know more
more muslim scholars being part of
public institutions i i'm a thorough
optimist i feel that the trajectory is
definitely going uphill uh despite the
all the hiccups that we are facing at
this point in time for political reasons
no i i don't agree that it's going
uphill
i think it's getting worse as of now um
since 2014 like a bee set
but i think yes there's definitely a
place to coexist because we have been
doing that since even before
independence right yeah thousand years
yeah we've so we have coexisted for so
long also i think the situation on the
ground like we're all the privileged
lord so let's accept that but even if
you see very common people on the ground
also i don't think there is as much as
divide as is being portrayed by the
media and the only reason the media is
portraying it is because the government
to its own benefit wants to push this
narrative that there is a hindu muslim
divide that muslims have been the cause
of your trouble they were the one whose
needs were always put forth and despite
being majority you were always neglected
so now we are going to look after you so
i think the media is just running that
narrative
full throttle since 2014 and it's just
becoming venomous like khabib said
fascism gets to you very very slowly
i'm i'm not very much comfortable when
you are saying after 2014 it had
happened so i am
i don't agree i don't agree on that with
you on that
thing
muslims and
hindus
if born in india can co exist very
peacefully and only we need to leave the
extreme our extremism so whatever
whatever may be that hindu extremism or
or the muslim extremism extremism is the
main issue which should be left behind
you better defend yourself
i think like you said it's a very
optimistic view it's very idealistic i
want it to happen i don't know if that
will happen
you're right we have existed together
for a very long time
we're barely existing together right now
when this is not a symbiotic
relationship we're not happy together i
personally blame it on the old guard i
think a lot of people have
prejudice because of the experiences
they've had and that's trickling down to
younger generations
perhaps
not to make it sound extremely dark but
if that generations die out and
conversations like these continue there
could be change but again keeping our
privilege in mind these conversations
are just happening here i am super
afraid of having these conversations
outside of these i am afraid of backlash
i am afraid of being othered i am afraid
of
being told that oh you know just go back
to pakistan where you belong then you'll
be comfortable there
so
i don't know if it's happening outside
of this sort of
in every educated household education is
very limited though again it's not that
limited definitely it's one of the
points that we have to focus on i wanted
to make the point out that why his
incorrigible optimism is not misplaced
things are bad right now of course
and is there fight between muslims and
hindus which weren't there earlier say
muslims came to india say one thousand
right
eight uh 80. were there wars before that
of course what they were muslims when
there was mahabharat what was their
discrimination before muslims came there
was a caste system there is nothing
particular about any one particular
community so hindus and muslims are not
that
you know unique pair who can never be
together
majority of us
agree that they can live together all of
us want them to live absolutely only
difference would be like you know how
much
so i think we should be optimistic i
implore all of you we certainly can lift
again before you just put our foots here
[Laughter]
[Music]
you